[Musique]
et pour en parler ce soir nous sommes
avec fabrice di vizio avocats des
professionnels de santé avocat
d'ailleurs de ses nombreuses plaintes
qu'on a vu dans ce sujet bonsoir ans
fabrice di vizio merci d'être avec nous
à vos côtés jacques myard mer et l'air
de maisons laffitte bonsoir à vous aussi
denis jacquet entrepreneurs également
est avec nous merci d'être là avoue
aussi denis jacquet alors olivier
verrons tout d'abord sur le terrain pour
tenter de mettre fin à la fronde des
maires sur l'approvisionnement vaccin
tous posent la même question les a
entendu longuement toute la journée où
sont les vaccins ils étaient se mettra
notamment aussi l ars de
seine-saint-denis pour livrer quelques
explications écouter le ministre de la
santé
nous n'avons pas à ce stade mais 6
millions d'accès nous sommes donc dans
un fonctionnement à flux tendu à chaque
fois que des vaccins ne sont livrés
toutes les semaines
immédiatement ils sont répartis dans les
neuf centres de vaccination dans
l'ensemble du territoire national et
donc à mesure que ces vaccins arrivent
nous ouvrons des créneaux de vaccination
alors que dit l'élu de terrain à
maisons-laffitte vous avez été livrés
vous jacques myard écouter dans les
yvelines et dans les bijoux sont autour
de nous il y a trois centres qui sont
prévus un et déjà ouverts il s'agit de
saint-germain-en-laye celui de
sartrouville auxquelles nous allons
aller il sera ouvert lundi le 25 et
l'après midi j'ai eu le médecin qui va
s'en charger qui va surveiller les
vaccinations
elle m'a dit je ne suis pas certain
d'avoir les doses dont il ya un vrai
problème de livraison et je crois que
tout ça ça se planifie à l'avance il y
avait un deuxième problème c'est qu'il
faut des gens aussi pour vacciner
et là j'ai fait un appel dans la
population pour savoir quelles étaient
les médecins les infirmiers fois à la
retraite qui était volontaire et là bon
point
une trentaine de vaccinateurs si je peux
me permettre cette expression se sont
prononcés volontairement
revenir vacciner donc qu'est-ce que ça
signifie ça signifie que ce soit pour la
livraison des vaccins
que ce soit pour les personnes qui
seront volontaires ça se prépare à
l'avance et là malheureusement on voit
bien que le gouvernement n'a pas su
réellement anticipé la livraison
j'ajoute que lorsque le ministre parle
de 900 centres sur la france c'est un
chiffre théorique parce qu'ils ne sont
pas tous armés comme on dit notamment
dans un certain nombre d'hôpitaux
donc il y à un membre de préparation les
vaccins vont arriver c'est certain il
est aussi certain que si vous essayez
d'avoir un rendez vous avez quelques
difficultés parce que à mon sens il eût
fallu diviser pour régner et à boire par
région un certain nombre de plates
formes qui permettent d'enregistrer les
demandes
un ami m'a dit qu'un 5h30 du matin il a
parfaitement rue les deux rendez vous /
dr libre mais c'était un 5h30 du matin
bon on est tous les français vont se
lever à 3 heures du matin pour essayer
prendre un rendez vous sur d'octo libre
logistique poussive manque de vaccins
une politique ans qui a une voix forte à
sonner la charge hier martine aubry
quand c'est flou il y à un loup dit la
maire de lille qui a réclamé la
transparence totale sur la question des
vaccins on réécoute martine aubry la
vérité il faut nous le dire
est-ce qu'on a ces vaccins ouest on n'a
pas assez qu'on le dit aux français
qu'on ne fasse pas comme le coût du
masque d'un fabrice di vizio le coût du
mas ne le connaissais très bien et cette
demande de vérité ça veut dire qu'il y
aurait un mensonge quelle est votre
analyse de la situation sur le front
désormais des vaccins le sage montre la
lune l'idiot regarde le doigt
c'est ça effectivement la position la
position c'est que vous êtes tous
entrain de disserter des questions
logistiques alors qu'à une première
question à se poser c'est est-ce que
vous parlez de vérité mais sur ces
populations âgées en particulier quand
moi j'ai vu les consentements
les formulaires de consentement qui sont
ceux des ehpad à destination des
résidents
excusez moi mais on est face à un
problème est la question de savoir si on
a assez de vaccins ou pas elle est
absolument pas la question on s'en fiche
vous avez un problème vous avez
autorités sanitaires qui vous expliquent
que le vaccin date a fait la
démonstration de son efficacité 75 ans
pas moi qui le dit c'est aussi sanitaire
qui le dit et on passe effectivement
vous parlez de vérité mais on passe
cette question complètement à côté de la
question sont filles de cette question
c'est pas un problème il faut vacciner
vaccinaux à tour de bras
venez donc une question on en a parlé
ici-même notamment le scepticisme des
français dont on parle régulièrement sur
cette antenne il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui le débat effectivement
c'est sur l'organisation parce qu'ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux tout de
même les français noirs se faire
vacciner fabrice di vizio tout de même
non mais attendez moi j'ai pas de
problème à l'idée qui veut se faire
vacciner simplement vous parlez de
vérité transparence j'ai le droit de
m'interroger sur le point de savoir si
cette transparence et cette vérité elle
est complète c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné j'entends çà et là des médecins
vous expliquer qu'il faut aller plus
vite qu'il faut effectivement revoir les
règles du consentement il faut pas
effectivement s'embarrasser que
consentement alors moi je veux bien que
vous discutez logistique nous ferons
discuter tant que vous voulez mais moi
ce que je voudrais être ce que voudrait
être sûr en tant qu'avocat des
professions de santé
d'abord c'est que les professionnels de
santé et effectivement on arrête de leur
mentir en disant qu'ils sont pas exposés
à un risque lorsqu'il vaque ci parce que
c'est pas vrai et quand effectivement
aux patients qu'ils aient bien la
conscience est bien de ce qu' ils
peuvent soudain l'accident et aucune
difficulté il faut qu'un consentement
soit libre et éclairé quant au reste
seule organisation qu'est ce que voulez
je vous dise
on a une organisation qui est à peu près
aussi nul que celle qu'on a eu au départ
qu'on a c'est qu'on a eu au milieu et
celle qu'on a maintenant ça continuera
comme ça jusqu'à la fin
fabrice rivière juste une petite
question parce qu'on est trois dans le
débat justement vous qui êtes au plus
proche des soignants que vous êtes
l'avocat de beaucoup d'entre eux comment
ça s'est passé pour eux rapidement un
leurs campagnes de vaccination
puisqu'ils étaient nombreux à être
supposé être vaccinés
parmi les prioritaires bah en fait pour
les échos que moi j'en ai ça a été un
petit peu le bazar parce que les
soignants qui souhaitaient se faire
vacciner parce qu'on est sur la base du
volontariat les soignants qui
souhaitaient se vacciner n'ont pas
réussi à pouvoir effectivement le faire
dans un temps raisonnable
il ya eu des couacs assez terrible au
niveau d'organisation en tout cas dans
certains hôpitaux en libéral s'est pas
beaucoup mieux
donc voilà les écoutes moi j'ai eu si
vous voulez en première intention sont
les échos d'une très grande
désorganisation
à l'époque vous donnez jacquet vous
aviez cherché à mettre en place une
filière d'approvisionnement de masse
pour les entreprises parce que
précisément le gouvernement était absent
c'est la même chose aujourd'hui pour les
vaccins on a un sentiment de
désorganisation qu'on nous dit pas toute
la vérité
écoutez on est obligé de se poser un
certain nombre de questions c'est vrai
parce que là la gestion de cette crise
et les catastrophiques depuis le début
alors c'est toujours facile en fait de
se donner l'impression en france qu'on
est les plus mauvais élèves
donc il faut quand même passer du temps
sur l'étude des autres cas bon si on
doit faire aujourd'hui un un championnat
du monde de l'efficacité c'est clair que
l'asie vient très très très très
largement en tête
non seulement parce qu'elles étaient
prêtes avant même mieux que ce virus
arrive du fait de l'expérience qu'elle a
vécue avec le star dans les années
précédentes mais surtout elle a prouvé
très tôt que ce virus n'était pas
mortelle à partir du moment où on était
préparé quand vous prenez une ville
comme hong kong vous avez pratiquement
sept mille habitants km² 157 morts en
neuf mois donc la première chose
effectivement c'est que il ya des gens
qui étaient prêt il ya des gens qui
savent traiter le problème il ya des
gens qui savent s'y prépare et qui ont
des résultats exceptionnels donc ça veut
dire que déjà on nous a vendu à
l'origine une maladie mortelle qui fait
que tout le pays devait être fermé ses
frontières fermées ces entreprises
dépecer et continuer le combat
aujourd'hui sans aucune raison valable
puisque c'est la désorganisation qui tue
c'est pas la maladie la maladie
malheureusement elle achève et elle tue
des personnes qui sont atteintes de
comorbidité qui a neuf dans neuf cas sur
dix ont plus de 75 voire 80 4 ans et
malheureusement qui accélèrent leur
lors des ses banques la deuxième chose
c'est qu'effectivement la logistique sur
l'approvisionnement des masques a été
une catastrophe voir un semis scandale
je pense qu'on peut aller jusqu'au terme
de scandales et aujourd'hui le ruz et la
même chose à on n'est pas très très loin
de nos voisins néanmoins il avant il
avance beaucoup plus vite
et là aussi il faut prendre les cas qui
marche quand vous êtes préparés à
l'avancé comme l'a fait israël vous
fonctionnez avec 1 1 million de vaccinés
on en croit en moins de quinze jours
trois semaines
alors qu'aujourd'hui en france on est
toujours à la traîne et que nos voisins
vont beaucoup plus vite les états unis
qu'on a pointé énormément du doigt sont
déjà à plus de deux millions de
personnes vaccinées
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont préparés
extrêmement tôt sur l'approvisionnement
ils ont s'ils sont assurés d'un certain
nombre de doses et là où je rejoins
monsieur division alors moi je suis pas
scientifique je suis pauvre
entrepreneurs qui se posent des
questions c'est qu'effectivement j'ai
toujours un doute très fort qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs la chine ne
veut pas vaccinés la suisse ne veut pas
vaccinés la suède attend mais un certain
nombre de pays dans le monde qui disent
il ya tellement de variants qu'on n'est
pas sûr que le vaccin pourra les traités
donc pourquoi se précipiter sur celui là
deuxièmement on n'a aucun recul sur ce
vaccin développé à toute vitesse
ça serait quand même bien d'en connaître
un petit peu les effets secondaires de
façon dont on commence jack et
pardonnez-moi avoir du recul injustement
hier d'ailleurs
les études ont affirmé que cinq
personnes
sondez fabrice division je sais que vous
vous ronchonner mais voilà il ya eu des
premiers retours tout même avec
d'ailleurs cinq belles riches ou de
pommes à domme et je dire je croyais je
ne passais pas ça le problème
je ronchonne poche ce pas là pour
enchaîner mais à un moment donné on
parle de vérité transparence regardez ce
que dit la has regarder effectivement ce
que dit le parlement lui-même ces
vaccins l'efficacité de ces vaccins sur
les plus de 75 ans n'a pas été prouvée
et démontrer vous imaginez bien
qu'effectivement on est dans un essai
clinique géant alors moi je dis pas
qu'il faut pas vacciner j'en sais rien
ce que je dis effectivement c'est que
concrètement à un moment donné il va
bien falloir le dire quand même aux gens
que cette efficacité n'a pas été
démontrée et que si elle n'est pas
démontrée ça veut dire quoi ça que
j'espère qu'on a un plan b quand même
j'espère qu'effectivement on entraîne
tout miser sur des vaccins et tout le
monde s'excite sur le vaccin mais
imaginez un instant que dans un mois ou
dans 1 mois et demi on découvre que 1 la
variole sud africaine est telle que le
vaccin ne marche sur personne ou pas
grand monde ou que deux effectivement le
vaccin soit les personnes âgées qui sont
les plus fragiles
il ne fait réellement pas la preuve de
son efficacité il faut justement la jaxa
je veux bien que vous critiquez la
vaccination de cette manière en dise on
n'a pas le recul nécessaire mais il n'en
demeure pas moins et axel kahn qui n'est
quand même pas un idiot et qui a une
certaine expérience médicale a affirmé
très nettement que ce vaccin avait quand
même une certaine efficacité et il faut
pas non plus exagérer
parce que son gamin et si vous n'êtes en
droit de dire ça monsieur
non monsieur messieurs s'est contredit
monsieur ce que vous dites est contredit
par totti sanitaire monsieur axel kahn
dit ce qu'il veut mais je vous invite à
lire je vous invite à lire les
recommandations techniques un instant
parce que vous affirmez droit d'écouter
il s'agit de lire et non monsieur je
n'affirme rien je lis monsieur août
affirme et rendez vous qui affirmez moi
je n'affirme rien n'est sûr jours
d'affilée
je relaie ce qu'elle visait le
professeur axel kahn qui a très
clairement dit que ce vaccin mais moi je
relève que dira cher monsieur vous
permettez un instant vous êtes peut-être
avocat mais le propre de l'avocate
écoutez donc ce qui est certain et les
crocos dumais réfection monsieur c'est
de rester l'année
monsieur si vous voulez créer à
l'émission tout seul ou la tête pressent
moi ça commence à bien faire
donc qu'il est évident il est évident
que sur ce point précis il est exact
qu'on n'a pas un recul énorme mais les
nombre exact que certains scientifiques
et pas des moindres tête le professeur
axel kahn disent que ce vaccin est
effectivement efficace et que donc ce
que vous demandez on l'aura
effectivement dans un an il n'en demeure
pas mois que la sociaux vous avez le
droit de dire ce que vous voulez le
droit de dire ce que vous voulez mais
voulait pas la journée vaccins et on a
des gars qui m'ont dit de ne pas se
mettre d'accord c'est que monsieur je
vous invite à lire une recommandation je
vous invite à négliger
je vous invite aussi à écouter des
professeurs émérites qui disent
exactement le contraire de ce que je
présiderai transparaître quelques
instants mais si vous voulez bien sûr la
question également des matchs que vous
connaissez bien aussi fabrice di vizio à
cause de la multiplication des variants
à la haute autorité de santé a changé
ses recommandations le masque en tissu
s'est notamment terminer je vous invite
à regarder cet écran les français
invités à privilégier le masque
chirurgical et à laisser aux soignants
le masque ffp2 qui est d'ailleurs
toujours aussi difficile à porter alors
qu'en allemagne en bavière le masque
ffp2 est obligatoire depuis hier dans
les commerces et transports ça nous
rappelle les débuts d'ailleurs de cette
pandémie quand on disait que le match
n'était pas obligatoire pour les laisser
elle essaie en tout cas c'est rare
masques aux soignants ça vous rappelle
justement cette affaire fabrice division
cette confusion autour des démarches moi
ça effectivement inspire de choses
j'espère que dans un voire pas nous dire
que le vaccin était finalement pas utile
parce que finalement on nous a vendu des
masques en tissu pendant neuf mois en
vous expliquant que c'était la panacée
que tout se valaient et que mon dieu il
fallait surtout pas effectivement m 2
ffp2 et à l'encore dit aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs parce que vous comprenez bien
c'est très difficile à porter il faut
pas emporté mais quand même la has
maintenant vous explique que les masques
anti fumée ça vaut peut-être pas tant
que ça les masques chirurgicaux des
justes pour target anglaise attention
hein parce que quand ça s'arrête au
niveau de la manche bah ça si c'est adam
en jeu ça marche pas mais alors j'espère
quand même effectivement comme cette
affaire qu'on va pas découvrir dans un
mois et demi dans deux mois avec du
retard que fondamentalement le ffp2 et
les masques le plus protecteur parce que
ça on sait qu neuf mois les allemands
eux ont bien compris puisque vous parlez
de la bavière
mais l'allemagne se pose la question
savoir si elle n'a pas le généraliser
sur tout le territoire et donc on
assiste à un phénomène ou regarder un
petit peu où on en est on à une
contamination qui augmentent enfin que
en dents de scie mais qui donc
apparemment augmente et on se pose pas
la question de savoir si le seul élément
qui restait ouvert tout du long et les
transports et pas contaminants on se
pose pas la question de savoir si
peut-être dans les transports les moyens
de protection qu'ils soient adoptés ne
sont pas les bons et bat l'allemagne se
pose la question et sont dits répondre
données jacquet l'entrepreneur que vous
êtes s'allumer inspire quoi
maintenant on est en train de glisser
vers les ffp2 prudemment mais sûrement
alors qu'on sait que voilà le marché est
inondé de tous ces jolis masques chinois
qu'on a touché est et d'ailleurs les
foyers certainement pas par dizaines
il ya aussi le évidemment l'aspect du
coup les ff et 2 sont beaucoup plus
chers oui alors ils sont effectivement
un petit peu plus cher en tout cas le
nom entre le mas de base chirurgicale
est ce qu'on appelle le 2er etc
ffp de honda on a quelques centimes
d'écart l'art heureusement ils sont
l'écart est beaucoup moins important
quand il ya une tension sur les marchés
au mois de mars ou d'avril où les prix
étaient complètement fou et et en plus
les totalement indisponible donc là
clairement on a quand même une
disponibilité aujourd'hui qui est
extrêmement forte et l'air heureusement
de ce que le privé s'est emparé du sujet
parce que si on avait dû laisser notre
approvisionnement à l'état vous laisse
imaginer dans quel état où seraient
aujourd'hui côté entrepreneur je peux
juste effectivement me continue à me
poser la question qu est la suivante
c'est quand on sait que neuf bon d'abord
comme le rappelait monsieur division on
a une contamination forte et malgré
cette contamination forte
on a un plateau légèrement montant ou
descendant depuis la fin du mois
d'octobre languereau qui varie assez peu
donc pas beaucoup plus
d'hospitalisations l'a toujours 2003
2004 2005
2500 personnes dans l'est dans les
de réanimation aujourd'hui un taux de
mortalité qui à part quelques jours ne
bouge pas trop et pourtant l'économie
est complètement fermée on est en couvre
feu à partir de 18h et on commence déjà
entendre la petite musique de
confinement la question que je pose
c'est à partir du moment où on a ce
plateau pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait
ouvre pas nos économies mais aujourd'hui
si on regarde toutes les études qui ont
été faites depuis les etats-unis depuis
l'europe
les deux seul continent qui vont en
pâtir très charmant et très durement
c'est l'amérique du sud et l'europe les
etats-unis vont s'en sortir la chine a
déjà rattrapé son pib au mois de
décembre 2020 tout le retard qu'elle a
pris en 2021 déjà et rattraper ceux qui
vont rester à la traîne et le notamment
sur le nombre de faillites qui va être
colossal en france qui est évalué au
doute de celui de nos voisins européens
c'est le nôtre donc moi je pose la
question de je suis à nice en ce moment
pour un certain nombre de raisons j'aime
monaco à côté a nice on a le couvre-feu
à 18 heures à monaco les restaurants
sont ouverts on a eu quatre morts à
monaco en neuf mois et tout est fermé
ici je vois pas pourquoi le virus ne
contaminerait peu comme pas dans les
restaurants à monaco et contaminerait à
nice donc je pense qu'on est en train de
tuer notre économie pour une raison qui
est pas la bonne
les clubs de sport sont fermés on sait
qu'elle est fréquenté par les 18 à 35
ans qui sont vraiment des quelques 0 0
quelques pour cent des cas donc moi je
pense surtout aux dégâts monstrueux aux
hommes et aux femmes qui vont perdre
leur job ne retrouveront jamais les
petits-moyens territoire qui vont perdre
leur entreprise est née reverront jamais
se demanderont pourquoi très rapidement
jacques myard parce que c'est vrai que
vous étiez 3 et ça a pris beaucoup de
temps de parole oui le mode est fait
pour vous effectivement on peut vraiment
s'interroger
il est exact notamment le traumatisme
pour les étudiants va être très fort
pour les économies il ya un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui vont être en
faillite c'est évident sur l'histoire
des masques moi même j'étais commandé
des masques en tissu rappelle que le
masque il est aussi pour protéger vous
protéger les autres plus que vous êtes
protégé des autres puisque c'est pour
éviter que ça vous plaise ou pas vous
savez fabrice séparera pas quand vous
éviter de cracher à la maison mais
monsieur vous raconter n'importe quoi le
problème c'est que vous racontez
n'importe quoi et les mains le problème
bouh procès affirmant par affirmation
qui sont des affirmations fausses
monsieur n'est pas bon mais un très
mauvais orateur donc jeu qu'à abu dis
c'est que ce serait très dur
le problème de cieux on n'est pas à la
figure des autres les masques même en
tissu avait un certain intérêt
alors maintenant on nous dit que c'est
laid ce même jamais eu de tvs contis eu
le bac mais il n'en demeure pas moins
il n'en devra pas moins que les masses
ont permis de d'arrêter un peu la
propagation mais où notre ami de nice a
raison c'est que on n'interdit pas le
véhicule de se transporter dans les rer
et le métro et que à partir de 18 heures
on reste chez soi et c'est là où
effectivement on peut s'interroger et le
comparatif avec monaco est assez évident
merci en tout cas à tous les trois pour
ce débat animé fabrice division jacques
myard et denis
jacquet en direct donc sur rt france
merci à vous